I
[Music]
thus the way of the world triumphs over
what in opposition to it constitutes
virtue triumphs over that which is the
essence lyst abstraction of essence
however it does not triumph over
something real but over the creation of
distinctions that are no distinction it
glories in this pompous talk about doing
what is best for humanity about the
oppression of humanity about making
sacrifices for the sake of the good and
the misuse of gifts ideal entities and
purposes of this kind of empty
ineffectual words which lift up the
heart but leave reason unsatisfied which
edify baraize no edifice declamations
which specifically declare merely this
that the individual who professes to act
for such noble atoms and who deals in
such fine phrases in his is in his own
eyes an excellent creature puffing up
which inflates him with a sense of
importance in his own eyes and in the
eyes of others whereas he is in fact
inflated with his own conceit virtue in
the ancient world had its own definite
sure meaning for it had and the
spiritual substance of the nation a
foundation full of meaning and for its
purpose and actual good already in
existence consequently to it was not
directed against the actual world as
against something generally perverted
and it as against a way of the world but
the virtue we are considering has its
being outside the spiritual substance it
is an unreal virtue a virtue and
imagination and name only which lacks
that substantial content the emptiness
of this rhetoric which denounces the way
of the world would be at once revealed
if the meaning of its fine phrases had
to be stated these therefore are assumed
to be something the meaning of which is
familiar the request to say what this
familiar meaning is would be met either
by a fresh flood of phrases or by an
appeal to the heart which inwardly says
what they mean which amounts to
admitting that it is in fact unable to
say what the meaning is the Thatcher
asst ness of this rhetoric seems to in
an unconscious way to have come to be a
certainty for the culture of our time
since all interest in the whole man
so such rhetoric and the way it is used
to boost one's ego has vanished a loss
of interest which is expressed in the
fact that it produces only a fleeting a
feeling of boredom
I had referenced this paragraph number
390 in this commentary by talking about
a distinction that Hagel is going to
make between virtue in the modern
context in his own time and in say maybe
the two three centuries before him and
projecting ahead and virtue in ancient
times as he's going to talk about it
here and I think it's worth dwelling on
on that a little bit he's going to begin
the passage by talking about the way of
the world triumphing over virtue but
we'll come back to that in a moment I
don't want to unpack the distinction at
the very beginning I want to think about
what he means here by virtue in ancient
times what would that extend to what
would that encompass so I think that we
could read that as continuing through in
the West that time period that was so
indebted to the ancients and so itself
in certain respects is an extension of
antiquity it didn't of course understand
itself in relation to antiquity as such
as as opposed to the modern that comes a
bit later but what I'm talking about
here is virtue is understood in the
medieval period it's complicated a bit
more because we introduce a explicitly
religious viewpoint in in there not to
say that other religious viewpoints are
not involved but Christianity comes on
the scene and reworks the ways in which
we we think about virtue but for the
most part what he's talking about here
in terms of a substantiality is really
much more ancient than than modern
similarly we could talk about
understanding virtue as presented in
other societies societies that may have
extended themselves into modernity but
have have retained that you might call
it specificity of the nation of the folk
of the call
sure that hagel thanks modernity has
managed to erode at least in in the West
he takes us by the way as a historical
not only development but a dialectical
progress of sorts but when it comes to
virtue it's actually reaching a kind of
dead end now that does not mean that
he's advocating for ancient virtue by
the way Hagel makes this clear in his
philosophy of history that he doesn't
think we can actually go back to say
ancient philosophies we can't
effectively be epicureans or stoics or
Aristotelian let alone you know citizens
of a Athenian polis or anything like
along those lines he thinks that that is
in a certain respect a mistaken and sort
of a regression of sorts but he's not
endorsing modern virtue at this point
either so all that said by way of
preface now let's take a look at what
he's saying so in the previous
paragraphs we've seen that as with the
two previous movements you know with
pleasure and the law of the heart what
we began with in this case virtue we're
going to oppose it to something else the
way of the world and it looked like
virtue had you know this reserve that he
talked about turned out that virtue is
not a very good fighter certainly not
when it comes down to it a philosophical
street fighter we might say and so like
he says the way of the world triumphs
over what in opposition to it
constitutes virtue now is this a sad
story about the great virtuous night who
is conquered by the evil way of the
world no because what Hagel is revealing
to us is that the virtuous night was
never what he pretended to be never what
he presented himself to himself and also
to others and thereby to the world
as being some of the better tendencies
were turned against him you know what
was involved in in virtue was an
acknowledgement of and a preoccupation
with a good that it was thought the way
of the world could not attend to the way
of the world was about selfishness the
way of the world was about lesser goods
well as it turns out when the good
becomes actual it exists in the world
that exists in reality it is vir click
right and Hegel saw that virtue had to
recognize all of those vir clica goods
in other people and in the ways of the
world and its workings and so therefore
the night of virtue couldn't take action
they could only posture you might say
there's going to be a lot of discussion
of posturing here so he goes on and he
says what does it triumph over it
triumphs over that which is the essence
lists abstraction of essence the vases
and lows abstraction izv eizan right so
essence has become essence lists because
it has become abstract so he goes out
and he says however I does not triumph
over something real what does that mean
that means virtue virtue in the modern
world is not something real it is
something ideal it and you know when we
talk about Hagel being an idealist and
an idealist you know are all about the
you know the thing out there or you know
thing in here in in our heart that is so
much better than everything out there
Hagel is not that sort of idealist Hagel
thinks that anything that remains merely
ideal is there by not only not actual
it's not even good it's not realizing
anything you know if we wanted to take
another famous philosophers dictum that
possibility is higher than actuality
that's not what Hagel things
hickel Hagel is more like a wrist
Italian in that respect so he goes on
and he says it doesn't triumph over
something real but what is a triumph
over the creation of distinctions that
are no distinctions we saw that in the
last paragraphs right it glories in this
pompous talk and here's now is where we
get the content of this ideal entities
and purposes and this rhetoric that he's
going to talk about right what is the
rhetoric well this is familiar territory
to us now because we've gone through
this part of the phenomenology it should
also be familiar territory to us because
people still talk like this in our own
time don't they this is something you
should think about applying so it goes
on and he says it glories in this
pompous talk about what doing what is
best for Humanity I'm going to save the
human race I'm going to straighten
things up because all those those other
people are too venial or blinded or
whatever it happens to be there they
can't step up to the plate and fix
things the way that I can fix things
what else about the oppression of
humanity i am going to liberate people
from false consciousness from their
ideologies from you know unfair
processes that that stereotype them that
keep them pushed down you know again
we've talked about this in the past
social reformers you know some social
reformers really have sort of emerged
from what we call the grass roots in
American parlance right others come in
from on high and they're going to fix
things and they go into say a poor
neighborhood they're like hey you know I
I sympathize with you I'm going to help
i'm gonna i'm going to contribute to
your lives and these people are like who
the hell are you why are you here in our
neighborhood we don't need you to fix
things if we want to fix things will fix
them ourselves or you know if you've got
some money to give us to fun stuff well
go ahead and do that and now get the
hell out of here i saw quite a bit of
this
when I was teaching in prison it was
interesting to see at least at Indiana
State Prison prisoners taking charge of
their own moral Reformation and and
being able to see through the do-gooders
who would come in and making the big
sacrifices for a pressed humanity they
would sometimes you know you say the
right things to these people to get what
they wanted out of them but they despise
them they were like you know you people
don't have a clue about what's going on
or how we're oppressed or anything like
that what else making sacrifices for the
sake of the good this is what the
virtuous person views him or herself is
doing as subordinating their own
individuality and I'm not denying that
many of them do in fact subordinate
their own individuality they pass up
career opportunities they you know end
up screwing up their family life they
end up you know losing out on money they
end up losing out on other goods because
they're dedicated to trying to change
the way of the world trying to make a
difference as we say but sometimes that
can become like Hagel saying that can
become a rhetoric that can become
something that's merely ideal something
that the person uses to tell them self
what a swell guy or gal they are and he
goes on and the last one the misuse of
gifts right now that would be both on
one's own side if I didn't use the gifts
that I have for the benefit of humanity
you know I could be using my let's say
we take rhetoric right I could be using
my rhetorical abilities to make a ton of
money in the advertising business or in
whatever other business but instead what
I'm doing is I'm devoting myself to your
cause and I'm helping you out and you
know this is quite understandable any of
us who are involved in doing you know
pro bono work or work for the common
good this is a tenancy
if we have to watch out for this
thinking that you know because we're you
know using our gifts for the purpose of
virtue which is supposed to be
liberating all their people you know
we're there by fighting the good fight
it's really easy for you know the very
you know selfishness and
self-centeredness and promoting the self
that we were supposed to be you know
suppressing or putting aside to in order
to promote virtue to sneak in there and
for for virtue to be as Hagel is saying
conquered by the way of the world the
way of the world conquers virtue not
just by standing fast in the face of it
but by encompassing virtue by showing us
that modern virtue actually does end up
becoming part of the way of the world so
he goes on and he says ideal entities
and purposes of this kind entities means
vases right we just talked about this
the virtue is a vasospasm it is an
essence less abstraction of essence and
it bases itself upon as Hagel says ideal
v's and right ideal entities ideal
essences if you like and ideal purposes
or end zeca so he says ideal entities
and purpose of this kind are what empty
ineffectual words now notice what Hagel
is going to do in this passage right
this is really great so Hagel doesn't
usually turn the rhetorical devices on
all that often if you did more often he
probably would be a little bit easier to
read wouldn't he but he tends to stay
away from that sort of thing he's
engaged in a very rigorous dialectical
exposition but in what comes here he
actually engages in a little bit of
rhetoric to talk about rhetoric he's
carrying out a meta rhetorical move so
he says these are ineffectual words
which lifts up the heart but leave
an unsatisfied literally leave reason
empty layer oh right so that's great and
then he says edify but raise no edifice
that's a translation of what in German
is air baon right they they they they
edify they they they build up in a
certain way but they raise no edifice
that out baon right there's no out
bowing going on on any sort of basis any
sort of foundation so this is a very
nice way of expressing it right a defy
betrays no edifice declamations which
specifically declare merely this this is
what this is what the action of the
person is and the words of the person
are really about showing this is what
Hagel's sayings unmasking them he says
the individual who professes to act for
such noble ends and who deals in such
fine phrases is in his own eyes an
excellent creature now he's not saying
that this is the case at every time he's
not saying that everybody who's striving
to do good in the world is a hypocrite
but he is saying that there is a shaping
a gestalt the shape of consciousness in
modern consciousness that does engage in
this sort of self-deception and
essentially it's becoming part of the
way of the world we see this over and
over and over again right we even make
movies about this where you know the
character originally is reacting against
some sort of injustice and they happen
to be smarter than the other people in
their poor neighborhood or you know in
there a rich neighborhood they they have
a nicer heart than the other people in
their original and they've got some
talents right all this this narrative is
going into that right and they take the
side of the good and now they have some
success right because people are like
hey will help this guy out you know he's
fixing the neighborhood he's
improving things for people well then he
starts getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and pretty soon he turns into the
problem he's become part of the way of
the world and there is always somebody
from his past is like hey man you sold
out you're not who you used to be you're
not for the ordinary person anymore and
they're right because at a certain point
something flips Hagel's saying that this
is a danger with in virtue now Hagel
says that this makes the person a
puffing up which inflates him with a
sense of importance in his own eyes and
in the eyes of others whereas he is in
fact inflated with his own conceit
there's something worth keeping in mind
you know we it you know it's one thing
for us to make celebrities out of people
who you know really don't have much to
offer us other than the fact that they
have celebrity it's another thing to say
you know those movers and shakers who
are trying to improve the world and just
happen to like put out all sorts of
videos showing about how much they are
improving world you know and then get
investors to come in and bankroll them
and you know get people to nominate them
for awards and stuff like that you know
it's another thing to say that those
people are somehow illegitimate or are
not entirely measuring up that's very
different kinds of celebrity but it does
become a kind of celebrity doesn't it
after a certain point we need to measure
whether there's really some substance
there we need it and how do we do that
we see whether it's more than just ideal
entities and ideal aims and more than
just a rhetoric Hagel goes on and he
says here's where we get to this
transition virtue in the ancient world
had its own definite sure meaning now
why why does he say that
this virtue doesn't have a definite sure
meaning it's trying to figure out what
its meaning is in the transition to
doing something in reality it thinks it
understands it really well but the proof
of that is putting it into the messy
pudding of reality and getting something
out of it something lasting what does
Hagel say virtue of the ancient world
had something else going for it it's
almost a different kind of virtue it had
him he says the spiritual substance of
the nation this is where we get to
talking about ethical substance right
here he's talking about spiritual
substance but we can also talk about
ethical substance because the ethical is
part of the spiritual for Hegel and when
you've got a society that has some mores
in place you can figure out what's good
and what's bad let's take Aristotle for
an example right so people say well
Aristotle so dated and it's a you know
an ethics of masters and these are based
on you know the cut the the what we
would call the Athenian gentlemen the
calc I got away right you know the
beautiful and the good together that's
not really something that appeals to us
that's all nonsense by the way you know
Aristotle it is in many respects as
applicable today you can think through
him in very productive ways foot put
that aside for a moment though let's say
that Aristotle really was you know and
let's say we identify him with ancient
Athens rather than ancient Macedon which
is you know he wasn't from Macedon he
was but he was from the north he was
never an Athenian citizen you know we
can go on and on about these historical
details let's say we do identify him
with ancient Athens and its spirit right
well there is something to that right if
you look at what he considers ver
used to be the paradigm of courage for
him is battlefield courage it's not
necessarily standing up to the tyrant
and saying hey that's unjust what you're
doing he does in fact say a lot of
boneheaded things about women in part
because he assumes the kind of society
that he's living in which was very you
know structured according to gender and
unequal ways and didn't allow for
development to take place in important
ways you know things that he probably
would revise today the very notion of
the great-souled or magnanimous person
as being at the pinnacle of the virtues
okay that you know if you read nikka
McCain ethics book for where he
discusses that you will find a lot of
very interesting references to rather
specific ways in which this person
should exist should exhibit himself
should act that's coming from the
ethical substance now what was the
problem with that well it was it was
restricted it was limited and that's why
we shifted to something more modern
that's why we got into this whole thing
in the first place remember back to the
very beginning the introductory section
of this portion of reason right the
ethical substance is abandoned first
then we have pleasure then the law of
the heart and then now virtue so he says
it found it had on the spiritual
substance of the nation a foundation
full of meaning and for its purpose an
actual good already in existence this is
something that separates ancient virtue
ethics again from contemporary talk
about virtue which is not necessarily
the revival of ancient virtue ethics but
say virtue is understood by mid moderns
and you know in say the the 18th and
19th century you were able to point
specific examples and say be like that
guy all right now he says consequently
there's another important thing coming
from this it was not directed against
the actual world as against something
generally perverted it didn't have the
same sort of world negating attitude
fundamental attitude that modern virtue
he has right it wasn't directed against
the way of the world so he says we're
not talking about this anymore that's
off the scene we're talking about this
what are we talking about them the
virtue we're considering has its being
outside of the spiritual substance
that's part of the transition and he
says it's an unreal virtue a virtue in
imagination and name only now that's a
problem it's not an actual virtue it's a
virtue that exists in the person but not
in the person by way of being a habit or
being you know you know sort of
structure of our matrix of relations
with other people and the world it's
something that has to be brought about
in the world but it hasn't been so eagle
goes on Tony says it lacks substantial
content and the emptiness of this
rhetoric which denounces the way of the
world would be at once revealed if the
meaning of its fine phrases had to be
stated so what is he referring to there
lots of people talk about virtue just as
much as in Socrates day anybody can talk
about virtue right and they're probably
not going to get challenged by most
people in part because most other people
are you know sort of either in on the
secret that nobody really knows that
virtue is or they have never thought
about it sufficiently and they're just
parroting those words and in the modern
period we get a lot of people talking
about virtue this is part of why virtue
falls out of favor because people are
like what what's
here there's really nothing here for me
well why the hell are we still talking
about virtue let's talk about something
that has substance instead something
that matters something that is nasally
right so he goes on and he says these
the fine phrases are assumed to be
something the meaning of which is
familiar the request to say what this
familiar meaning is would be met by one
or two things a fresh flow of phrases
again we can think back to Plato's
question you know Socrates questioning
people well what do you mean by that
none that it regurgitates some more
stuff and he's like yeah I don't know
that that actually answers my question
there echoes that becomes a particularly
acute problem in modernity isn't it what
do we mean can we explain it to our
satisfaction can we explain it to
somebody else's satisfaction does it
matter if we can't explain it to
somebody else if we at least feel that
we understand it well that's the second
option right instead of just a flow of
words you refer to the loo I've got it
in my heart I know what it is what does
Hagel say about that he says the appeal
to the heartwood inwardly say what they
mean and what does that amount to
admitting that it is in fact unable to
say what the meaning is that's a problem
as well so it goes on and he says the
fed to assist us of this rhetoric seems
in an unconscious way and now he's
talking about his own times and culture
now this is even more so for our own
culture has become a certainty for the
culture of our time all interest in the
whole mass of such a rhetoric and the
way it is used to boost one's ego has
vanished now that's being a little
optimistic I think isn't it because this
is a perennial issue that keeps coming
up we wouldn't be talking about it today
if it wasn't still an issue but he says
our age doesn't believe in this nonsense
anymore
loss of interest which is expressed in
the fact that it produces what a feeling
of boredom when people talk about virtue
let's put aside the word virtue let's
make it more contemporary when people
talk about integrity when people talk
about goodness when people talk about
making the world a better place you've
heard these phrases over and over again
do you like sort of tune out when that
rhetoric comes up if so that would be
part of what he's talking about here I
think there are many people who are like
that's all nonsense I don't believe you
when you talk about that sort of stuff
show me what you're actually talking
about make it actual not just ideal and
then I'll listen to you but then we
might be talking about something quite
different that is the conundrum that
virtue has gotten itself into